[ "Love Story" plays ]
♪ She fills my heart
with very special things ♪
♪ With angel songs,
with wild imaginings ♪
Token, we are running
out of time.
If you don't let me
cheat off of you,
I'm going to tell your parents
that you saw "Black Panther"
in the theater
without them.
I didn't see "Black Panther"
in the theater!
Of course you did,
Token!
That's why me ripping on it
pissed you off so much!
I swear
on my mother's life.
I don't care what you said
about "Black Panther."
Goodbye.
But, Token,
I don't understand!
If you didn't see it
and you really don't care
that I ripped
on "Black Panther,"
then why won't you
let me cheat --
Oh, my God.
You don't care what I said
because you did see it...
and you...
didn't like it either.
[ Gasps ]
That's what this
is all about, isn't it?
You hate yourself for seeing
through the mirage like I did,
And that's why you wouldn't
let me cheat off you!
Well, I didn't write
"Black Panther," Token!
It isn't my fault
it sucked!
Why go after me?
But now, it's over.
Don't worry.
They're not gonna know
you didn't like "Black Panther,"
so long as you never make me
fail another math test.
Well, we're probably both
gonna fail now
because fourth period
already started.
What?
No!
We have to take that test,
Token!
Come on! We can still get
to class on time!
[ Gunshots ]
Oh, great.
Come on! We can do this!
[ Gunfire, people screaming ]
Billy!
Give me your lunchbox!
[ Bullets ricocheting ]
Butters!
It's the entire glee club
this time!
Butters,
I have to get to class!
The math quiz
is starting!
Oh, crap!
The math quiz?
It's already
fourth period?
I can't flunk
this math quiz, Butters!
Cover me!
Well, okay!
Waaaaargh!
Wargggggghgghghh!
[ Gunfire ]
[ Music continues ]
♪ How long does it last? ♪
♪ Can love be measured
by the hours in a day? ♪
[ Glass shatters ]
[ Slow-mo scream ]